معنا في الاستديو مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه لموارد الطاقه سيد جفري بيادسه
مرحبا بك معنا سجلفي لاحظنا خلال السنه
الفائته كان هناك التزام امريكي
بالدعم السياسي والعسكري الاوكرانيا ماذا
عن الدعم بمجال الطاقه خاصه مع تركز
الهجمات الروسيه الاخيره على بنيه الطاقه
في اوكرانيا
حيث تجتمع افراد الاسره الدوليه من اجل
الدعم النظام الدولي الذي اسس للازدهار مع
احترام السياده الترتي نقطه واجهه حول
الطاقه انا عدت الى كيف الشهر الماضي
لارام يحصل
مع هذا الجهود الروسيه لاستخدام فصل
الشتاء كاسي سلاح
والاعتداء على
البنيه التحتيه الخاصه بالطاقه من اجل
حمله اوكراني على تقديم تنازلات والتخلي
عن مستقبلها نحن نعمل جاهدين مع كافه
الشركاء الدوليين اليابان دول
سبعه وهمم كل الدول حتى يكون لي اوكرانيا
الادوات التي تحتاج الى هذه المواجهه
الازمه الانسانيه التي تحاولوا روسيا تسبب
بها من خلال الاعتداء على الطاقه
ولكن ما هذا سوى جزء من استخدام روسيا
لهذه الاسلحه التي وهذا حمله بدات منذ
سنوات
يطلب مساعده امريكا في خصوص مجال الطاقه
ما الذي جرى تقديمه حتى هو يعني ذهب الى
مثل هذه المناشده للجانب الامريكي
تحدث عن اهميه ان يكون لاوكران الموارد
التي تحتاج اليها للحفاظ والدفاع عن شبكه
الطاقه وكذلك تصدي للهجمات المريعه
الروسيه ضد مستشفيات مصانع الطاقه التحويل
لثلاثه الازمه الانسانيه التي تسببها
روسيا مع هذا الهجمات بما فيه ايضا ماساه
ما رايناها في ايام الاخيره همم
بالاضافه الى الصور الرهيبه حيث كان احد
قال صواريخ الروسيه
وقتل 40 شخصا همم في مجال الطاقه الاوروبي
لطالما تحدثت الولايات المتحده بانها ملت
بهذا الشان خاصه مع يعني استخدام الطاقه
كاسلاح ما بين الجانبين روسيا وايضا من
قبل الاطراف الغربيه وفرض سقف لسعر النفط
والغاز الروسي همم الطرف الاوربي وجه
انتقادات للجانب الامريكي فيما يخص
الاستجابه السريعه لموضوع الطاقه وامداد
اوروبا وايضا فيما يخص الاسعار المرتفعه
همم ما الذي تنوي الولايات المتحده القيام
به في المرحله القادمه لدعم الشركاء
السعوديه
الى انه من خلال استخدام
روسيا لقد فقدت مصداقيتها كموردا موثوق
ذلك على وجه الخصوص في اوروبا
عن تلقي الغاز عبر الانابيب من روسيا وهذا
قد هز وصدم الاسواق العالميه
اليوم طلعت دوله قطر
مع دوله قطر ايضا الولايات المتحده قد
حشدت مولدها عن خاصه
في اوروبا بل في افريقيا ايضا وجنوب اسيا
وفي ارتي ساري السماء وكذلك المواد
الغذائيه كل ذلك
وهما قمت به روسيا
لن تعتبر يوما بعد الان ورد موثوقا
شاركتنا مع دول مثل قطر بالغه الاهميه
لهذا السبب وماذا عن الجانب الامريكي
المطالب بضروره خفض اسعار الطاقه من قبل
الشركه الاوروبي خاصه مع هذه الازمه التي
تدفع اوروبا الثمن الاكبر فيها
الاسعار
كبيرا في فصل الربيع مباشره بعد الاشتياق
حيث انا الاسواق كانت خائفه
من الغاز
ذلك
تقوم بها دوله قطر
نعم الى التقدم في نواحي الطاقه البديله
كمصدر رئيسي خاصه بعد ما جرى بين الجانب
الاوروبي والمورد الروسي بالنسبه للغاز
والطاقه بشكل عام
سوف يحتاج الى الكثير من كميات الطاقه من
كل نوع نريد ان نحرص على حصول ذلك بطريقه
تقلل من تاثير ذلك على المناخ اي التخفيف
البصمه الكربونيه وذلك من خلال المصانع
العامل على الفحم الحجري والغازي طالع
بدور اساسي في الولايات المتحده تبرير
الاساسيه لتخفيف البصمه الكربونيه هي نقل
المصانع الكهربائيه من الفحم الحجري الى
الغاز
على همم
طاقه من الرياح والشمس اذا لقدري
اينما يحصل حين نستفيد
من هذه
التقنيات الجديده هذا كله جزءا من عملنا
تجاهها حمايه المناخ نفعل ذلك بموجب
فقط باريس المناخيه شكرا لك ضيفنا في
الاستديو مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
لموارد الطاقه جفري بيات شكرا على
المشاركه معنا